So our next class of
biomolecule that we're going to
talk about are
nucleic acids.
And we can, for the most part,
describe their properties
by considering just covalent
bonds and hydrogen bonds.
Although,
that's a bit of an
oversimplification.
But, anyway,
these are, again,
polymers.
So this is DNA and RNA,
terms you've
undoubtedly heard.
And these are made by splitting
out water.
And,
in this case,
the monomeric units are given
the special term
nucleotide.
And a nucleotide consists of a
sugar with something
called a base on it.
It's got a phosphate group at
one
end and a hydroxyl group,
one of the sugar hydroxyls that
we saw the
other day at the other end.
The B stands for base.
And the way the bond is formed,
as I
said, is by splitting out water
like that to form what's known
as a
phosphodiester bond.
And we'll be talking a lot
about those when we
talk about DNA and RNA in more
detail later on in the course.
The
sugars are pentoses where N
equals 5.
We were talking about these the
other day.
The base goes in this position.
That's the 1 position
of the carbon.
This is the 5 position of the
carbon.
And this is where the phosphate
is located.
This sugar is
called ribose.
And then RNA,
which is the polymer of
nucleotides that
have ribose as the sugar is
ribonucleic acid or RNA,
as you've
known it.
If this hydroxyl here is
replaced by a hydrogen and the
rest
of it's the same --
-- this is deoxyribonucleoside.
And if you polymerize that
together then
you get DNA or deoxyribonucleic
acid.
The bases come in two flavors.
And this will be on your
handout.
Ones
that either have two rings,
adenine or guanine.
And the general term of
those is purine or they have
one ring of pyrimidine.
And in DNA one
finds cytidine and thiamine
abbreviated as C and T.
Or in RNA,
instead of finding thiamine you
find uracil, which is the same
except
that it doesn't have the methyl
group that's present at this
position on thiamine.
And the important thing about
these
particular nucleotide bases is
that they can form hydrogen
bonds in a
very special way.
It's diagramed on here that
this is a guanine pairing
with the cytidine,
so a G pairing with a C.
And you can form three
hydrogen bonds.
Or between an A,
an adenine and a thiamine you
can form
two hydrogen bonds.
Those are just the things we
were
diagramming on the board the
other day.
And those are the forces that
hold the strands of DNA
together so that DNA is the
double helix,
as you
know.
It's basically a backbone with
sugars and phosphates.
And
then there'll be some sequence
of bases down this.
And then on the
other strand you'll have the
base that can form hydrogen
bonds with this.
So C, there would be three
hydrogen
bonds here.
This would be a G on this side,
again, three hydrogen
bonds.
If there's an A here that will
be a T there,
two hydrogen
bonds.
And so on down.
And we'll talk about the
implications of this
later in the course when we
talk about DNA replication,
but for the
moment I think your eye can
see, you can probably see that
the geometric
arrangement of these is just
exactly the same,
whether it's a G-C or it's
an A-T base pair.
You can superimpose them,
and they have just
exactly the same molecular
structure.
And that's really crucial for a
lot of things having to do with
DNA.
So, as you know,
it's not just sort of a ladder
with hydrogen bonds.
It's twisted in 3-dimensional
space.
That's the double helix.
And in
that little movie I showed you
the nitrogen atoms and the bases
are
blue so you can pretty much
pick it out that there's a
series of
hydrogen bonds going right down
the middle of a DNA molecule
with the
phosphoribose backbone on the
outside.
So every one of your cells,
since you have about 3 billion
base pairs
you have two point something
times that many hydrogen bonds
holding
your DNA together.
The thing to remember about the
strength of the
hydrogen bond,
it's about a twentieth a
covalent bond,
and so
you're able to pull those
things apart and then put them
back
together at physiological
temperature while leaving all
the
covalent bonds that make up
each strand of the DNA leaving
those intact.
It's also possible,
since RNAs are
usually single-stranded,
that if you have a little
sequence here that has
the complimentary sequence over
there then these can pair like
this
forming a hairpin or some
little structure like that.
And, again,
we'll talk about transfer RNAs
which play a really key role in
protein
synthesis.
They're the little translators
that go back and forth
between the nucleic acid code,
the genetic code and the
protein code,
which is written in amino
acids.
And this just shows making an
RNA
copy for a tRNA gene from the
DNA, but then these are the
relationships
between the complimentary
sequences right in that strand.
So this thing
is able to fold up into a sort
of cloverleaf structure that
some of
you have certainly probably
seen at some point.
It's a little bit
twisted here because you can
see how the complimentary
sequences have
found each other.
And even though this is just a
single strand of RNA,
by forming hydrogen bonds to
complimentary
sequences within itself it can
take up a structure.
And I'll show you.
It actually goes on,
there are some other forces
that come in.
And this
will fold up into a
3-dimensional structure that
goes even beyond what
I've shown you,
but we won't need to talk about
that for just a little
bit. OK. So then the next --
-- class of molecules that
we're going to spend a lot of
this course
on are proteins.
And these are polymers again.
-- made by splitting out water.
So
that's been true of
polysaccharides.
It's true of nucleic acids.
It's
true of proteins.
In this case the monomers are
structures
known as amino acids.
And they have an amino group.
And
then it's joined to a carbon
known as the alpha carbon.
And then
there's a carboxyl group.
So this is why they're called
amino acids,
because their carboxyl group is
an acid.
And the way they form --
We'll give these different side
chains here.
I'll tell you about
these side chains in just a
minute.
The way these form a bond is by
splitting out water here.
And then this will give this
very important
bond in nature --
-- which is known as the
peptide bond.
And there's a chemical
property of this that's
important.
Someone was bemoaning the fact
that
I had to go over a bunch of
chemistry and they hadn't liked
5.011.
My apologies.
But we won't be spending all
course
doing chemistry.
But if you want to understand
how these things work you
do need to understand some of
the chemical principles to
understand
them.
And this is a case where it's
really important because,
although
it's written this way with the
double bond here and a single
bond
there, this double bond
actually sort of spends part of
its time over
here.
So this is actually sort of a
partial double bond.
And that has
an important consequence
because if you're a single bond,
if you
remember a single bond can bend
and stretch but it can also
rotate.
But if you're a double bond you
cannot rotate.
So the peptide bond,
and you make a lot of these
when you're polymerizing amino
acids
together to make proteins,
those bonds have a very special
character
that they cannot rotate.
Now, let me say,
I'll come back and show you
why that's important in just a
moment.
But let me just say a word
about the side chains.
There are 20 different amino
acids.
And they have side chains that
have very different chemical
properties.
And when we start thinking
about how a chain of amino acids
take up the
properties that make it into an
enzyme or part of a motor or a
structural protein or into your
finger nails or your hair or
skin,
they have to have very special
properties.
And it's the sequence
of these different amino acids
with their different chemical
properties
that are eventually going to
let each protein form up to one
particular 3-dimensional
structure that will give it its
characteristics.
So the different types of amino
acids, and again you won't have
to memorize these,
but here they are up
here.
But let me just point out the
important classes,
because the thing
you really want to do with this
one is to remember the types of
amino
acids we find.
There are negatively charged
amino acids.
An example of this would be
aspartate.
Under physiological
conditions, although this is an
acid, it will dissociate so it
will
have a negative charge.
And that's abbreviated as
A-S-P.
Glutamine is
another one that has a negative
charge.
There are also amino acids
that have positive charges on
the side chain.
An example of this would be
lysine which has four methylene
groups.
And then it has an amino group.
But, again, under physiological
conditions, around pH 7,
that will be protonated so it
will have a plus
charge.
And that is lysine or L-Y-S.
And arginine and histidine
are two other amino acids that
have a positive charge,
or can
have a positive charge.
Then there's a set of amino
acids
that have a polar character.
They don't have a full charge.
And, as
you might guess,
they have one of the bonds that
we've talked about
that are polar. This is serine.
Serine.
There's another one that has a
hydroxyl that's
known as threonine.
And then there is a glutamine
and
asparagine, both of which have
an N-H bond.
So just through what I've
told you here,
we haven't even been through
the set, you can see how you
can begin to decorate an amino
acid chain.
So there's a plus charge and
a minus charge,
a polar charge.
There's a tremendous amount of
diversity because at every
single thing you have a choice
of 20 things
you can put in.
So they not only have size and
shape characteristics,
but they have particular
charges and other properties.
Then, as always,
there are a bunch of special,
oh, excuse me.
Actually, before we do that,
we have hydrophobic.
Or you could think of these as
greasy or water-hating.
These are the ones that are
sort of when I was
talking about trying to
dissolve butter into water.
These are things that don't
like to interact with water or
cannot
interact with water,
and so they cannot form
hydrogen bonds so you
cannot get them to go under
water easily.
And they come from very
simple ones that have just the
methyl group which is alanine or
A-L-A or one like this which
would be CH2-CH with a couple of
methyl
groups.
This is even more water-hating,
that would
be lucine, L-E-U.
Or here's one that you probably
could guess that really doesn't
interact with water.
This is
phenylalanine or P-H-E.
And you can see what this side
chain is.
It's a
methylene group.
And what's dangling off it but
a benzene ring.
And I think most of you
remember from probably beginning
chemistry
that benzene is something that
you cannot dissolve sugar
in or something.
It's an organic solvent.
It will
only dissolve things that have
a very hydrophobic character.
Then
there are some special cases.
Glycine is one,
because in this case the side
chain is simply a hydrogen
atom.
And, as a consequence to that,
this is a very flexible amino
acid.
So if you want to build -- If
nature wants to build a loop
into
a protein, it's going to
undergo a tight turn.
You often find glycines
there because there's not a big
side chain to get in the way if
you're
going to be bending the chain
in 3-dimensional space.
Another one is
cysteine, which looks like
serine over there,
but it has a thiol group
instead of a hydroxyl group.
And that's important because
that
allows for the formation of
another special type of bond
that if you
have one chain of protein that
has a cysteine on it and another
polypeptide chain that has a
cysteine on it and they're close
together in space,
what can happen is you can form
a covalent bond
between these under oxidative
conditions.
This is known
as a disulfide bond.
That's covalent.
So those two
chains, if that bond occurs,
are now sort of
semi-permanently locked
together.
They're locked together in a
very, very strong way.
So this
is a feature of,
this is the only intrastrand
covalent bond that you'd
characteristically find in
proteins.
All the rest of them we're
going to
show you, when they fold up in
3-dimensional space,
depend on other
kinds of interactions.
And finally there's one last
case
which is proline.
And this one is a little
different because in the
amino acid the side chain bends
around like this and joins here.
So
it's actually forming a little
circle here between the
nitrogen,
the amino group and the
carboxyl group.
And the consequence of this is
this bond cannot rotate.
The bond that
would normally be able to
rotate is not able to do that.
And so this is
the sort of amino acid you find
that when there are some of
these regular
structures, I'm going to show
you in a minute,
like helices and things,
this protein won't,
this amino acid particularly
won't fit into those
structures.
So you tend to,
if nature wants to interrupt a
particular regular structure
that's coming,
it will often find a proline
right at that particular point.
OK.
So what we've talked about up
until now is sort of just the
very, very basic piece of
protein
structure.
It's what called the primary
structure which is nothing more
than
the sequence of amino acids.
However, here's a little piece
of
protein.
This is polyalanine.
And one thing you can sort of
see is if
I was trying to figure out how
to fold this up into a
3-dimensional
confirmation.
And let's say this had 300
amino
acids or something,
there are essentially an
infinite number of
confirmations.
And so one of the real holy
grails still in biology is
trying to understand if you see
the linear sequence of an amino
acid,
which we can now deduce,
excuse me, of a protein,
of an amino.
If you
see the linear sequence of
amino acids in a protein,
and we can
deduce those from analyzing
genomes and so on,
how do we go from a thing
that says a tryptophan,
a cysteine, a serine,
a serine, a threonine,
whatever down the chain to
finding its 3-dimensional
structure and
ultimately its role?
And you can sort of hopefully
get a
sense from this of why it's
important.
So there are levels this
goes.
The next level is what's known
as secondary structure.
These
are regions of local secondary
structure and they're determined
by
hydrogen bonds.
And I'll show you how these go
in
just a second.
And then you can think about
proteins in the tertiary
structure.
So what we've done and sort of
taken a chain and then found
out how a little region might
take up a particular,
for example,
here's
a portion that's in a helix.
This is fairly rigid right now
because of
the way it's held together.
And we'll then find maybe
another region
like a beta sheet I'm going to
show you in a minute.
Ultimately we have to figure
out how all these units fold up
into a
3-dimensional structure.
And what we get there is called
the tertiary
structure.
And this has some other forces
we're going to talk about
besides covalent bonds and
hydrogen bonds that determine
that.
And
then, as I've tried to tell
you, you can see that proteins
play a lot of
roles in nature and they're not
all single proteins running
around being
an enzyme or something like
that.
Many of them are parts of
machines
so they're made to fit together
in absolutely beautiful ways.
Some of
them have, at this point,
fifty-hundred parts that all go
together fitting shapes and
interacting with these shapes on
the
principles that we'll be
talking about here,
the different forces
that make things happen in
nature.
And so quaternary means the
structure when there's more
than one polypeptide chain.
So getting a handle on protein
structure was kind of a very
important intractable problem
for a
long time because it was just
too hard a nut to crack,
but in the
1930s and 1940s x-ray
crystallography started to come
into
usage where basically you'd
bounce x-rays off of a crystal.
And then they would refract and
you'd see characteristic
reflections.
And you could work backwards to
figure out what the
structure of the crystal was.
This had been applied to
minerals and a
lot of structure,
but it hadn't been applied to
proteins.
When people
started to look they found
there were certain proteins that
gave
characteristic reflections.
Keratin, for example.
Your hair
gives a characteristic
reflection around 5.4 angstroms.
So that
suggested that there was a
repeating unit somewhere in
keratin
that had this.
And, again, with artificial
peptides
sometimes they were able to see
these reflections.
And so that was
where things stood for a while.
And then one of these secondary
structures, a very,
very important one known as the
alpha helix was
deduced by Linus Pauling.
Some of you have heard of him.
He was a
famous chemist at Caltech.
He got the Nobel prize.
He also got famous
later in his career because he
championed the use of vitamin C
to
cure every ill known to
mankind, including the common
cold.
Although there's some merit to
what Linus stated,
he probably overstated
some of those later findings,
but his contributions to the
underlying
chemistry and biochemistry of
proteins was amazing.
And he was
the one that figured out the
structure that explained the
5.4 angstrom repeat.
And it was kind of an
interesting
story.
He was in Oxford,
England.
And he got sick.
I think it was
some time in the winter.
And he got bored reading
detective books after
a while so he thought he'd try
and figure out the structure of
proteins
that gave rise to this
characteristic repeat.
So he made a
simplifying assumption.
He decided he'd forget all the
side chains and
just focus on this peptide
backbone just with the peptide
bond.
And he was a chemist.
And he knew,
what I just told you,
that this had
a partial double bond character
so it couldn't rotate.
And he reasoned
that this was held together by,
since these things could form
hydrogen bonds that this was
probably forming a hydrogen bond
with a carboxyl group of some
other amino acid and this was
probably
forming a hydrogen bond with an
amino group of a different
amino acid.
And so what he did was he made
a
sort of chain like this and he
started to pleat it at the alpha
carbon, which is the one that
has the side chain on it,
and was
trying to find the structure
that would let him do this.
And
basically what he found was
that if he made a helix that
looks something
like this, right-handed helix,
and he could get a repeat
structure that
allowed him to form a hydrogen
bond.
And the repeating unit was 5.4
angstroms and 3.7,
excuse me, amino
acids per turn.
And it's a right-handed helix.
It's the same
sort of thing if you're trying
to turn in a screw.
It's got that kind
of structure.
And this shows you a little
movie of an alpha helix.
You
can see this is just showing
the backbone.
So this is the part you
can look right down the end of
it.
See how you can look right
though?
And you can see how the
hydrogen bonds are formed by
turning this
thing into this regular
structure.
And the neat thing about this
then
is if you put on the side
chains, and you can put them on
in any
order, you can build a
tremendous amount of diversity
even within that
helical structure.
I think I can stop this.
I just want to show you
one thing, if I can manage to
this when it comes around again.
Stop it there.
One of the things you can see,
now
we're looking down the helix.
And although you won't
recognize the
structures of all the amino
acids right away,
you may be able to see
in this particular one.
Here are a couple of aromatic
rings off on this
side.
So this side of the helix
wouldn't like to see water,
and over
here are a bunch of charged and
polar amino acids.
So you could see
how you could build into a
helix like that,
a surface, one part that
wouldn't like to interact with
water and another part that
would.
So that was an extremely
important contribution.
And there are alpha
helices in almost all proteins.
They'll be in little chunks
coming
down an amino acids chain.
But they'll take up that
structure.
And, as you can see,
it's driven by these hydrogen
bonds that we've been
talking about.
There turns out then to be a
second type of secondary
structure that's important.
It's called a beta sheet.
And in this case you can either
line up two polypeptide chains
running in
the same orientation,
amino to carboxyl,
or you
can run them in opposite
orientations,
amino to carboxyl,
amino to carboxyl in the other
way.
The latter one is called an
anti-parallel beta sheet.
And if you line things up this
way
you'll see you can find
hydrogen bonds between the
chains like that.
So this allows two things to
form in this way and gives a
sort of
sheet-like structure.
Whereas, that alpha helix has
this tight coil like
this.
So over here I think we have a
movie of a beta sheet.
And you'll
see again you can build up more
than one.
Because if you look up here you
can see how you are all set up
to form
more hydrogen bonds out in that
kind of way.
And, as I said,
you can do
this same trick putting the
polypeptide chains so they have
the
same polarity.
And so you can approximate,
look at the structure
of most proteins then by
depicting them either as alpha
helices, which
you'll see in these diagrams.
You've already seen a few
in the examples given.
They'll look like this.
Or a beta
sheet which are indicated as
these flat arrows.
So here's a little
piece of a protein made up of
alpha helix, these beta sheets.
What this
is, actually,
is a piece of the BRCA-1 gene.
That's the familial
susceptibility to breast
cancer.
The gene that causes that is
called
BRCA-1.
And it has a special
interaction domain called
the BRC T domain.
This is the structure.
And the only
point I'm trying to make,
it's of a protein that's
involved in
preventing you from getting
breast cancer.
If you get a mutation in
it, or particularly in this
region, for example,
you can end up with an
increased susceptibility to
breast cancer.
But what is it?
It's an
alpha helices beta sheet.
There's green fluorescent
protein.
You've
seen that a few times.
Maybe now you'll recognize it's
mostly made of
beta sheets.
There's a little bit of alpha
helix down there,
a little
bit right there.
And that has the property that
we've
talked about of fluorescing.
This is a protein I'll tell you
later on
that recognizes mismatches in
DNA, and you get a
susceptibility to
cancer if it breaks.
The only thing you notice here
are a lot of alpha
helices in it.
And hopefully already your eye
can begin to pick
these out.
This is an enzyme.
What it does is it's got a
catalytic
ability to cleave other
polypeptide chains.
The functions of these
don't matter.
But you can see once again
alpha helices beta sheets.
Here's another one.
It looks just about the same,
alpha helices,
beta
sheets, except in this case
this is the human gene known as,
the protein
encoded by human genes called
RAS.
That's an oncogene.
That's a gene
that if it mutates in a
particular way will cause the
cell that has
that to move a step down the
pathway to cancer.
So what I've done is put
up a whole lot of structures
that have some alpha helices,
some beta sheets.
But you can get the idea that
you
can get very,
very different biological
activities from just
depending on how you arrange
those.
OK.
So there are a couple of other
then forces that I need to tell
you about if we're going to go
all the
way to understanding the
3-dimensional structure of
proteins.
What we can get to from that is
alpha helices beta sheets.
But you saw there were loops,
there were other interactions
that I
haven't accounted for in
showing you those 3-dimensional
structures.
So
one of them is ionic bonds.
This is the third class of
force.
This
is an extreme case of electron
sharing where one atom gets all
of
the electrons.
So aspartate,
which I had up on the board,
aspartic acid
looks like that,
but under physiological
conditions the oxygen
will get all the electrons and
you'll have a hydrogen on it.
And a consequence of that then
is that if you have a
polypeptide chain
that over here has an aspartate
and over here has a lysine,
which is the
four methylene groups,
and the positively charged
thing here, you
can get an ionic bond between
those two amino acids that can
be very far
apart on the polypeptide chain.
There may be a lot of amino
acids in
between, but what they then do
is bring these two points
together and
hold them like that.
The next class of force is kind
of tricky.
You may
have heard of it in chemistry.
It's referred to as van der
Waals interaction.
And the basis of this,
without going
into it too much,
is even a nonpolar bond --
-- can have a transient
polarity.
And this then induces --
-- a transient polarity in a
nearby bond.
And it has to be a really
So about 0.2 to 0.4 nanometers.
Remember, covalent
bonds are roughly half that
distance or something.
So it's got to be a
very, very close interaction.
It's weak.
It's only one-third to
one-quarter of a hydrogen bond,
which you may recall is about
one-twentieth of a covalent
bond.
But there can be many,
many of them
if the surfaces fit together
really, really tightly.
So if you have a
protein fold,
so there's a surface here,
and then it folds up in such a
way that there's a surface
here, then you can get a lot of
van der
Waals interactions down here.
Now, I've never had a really
good way of
explaining this.
But today, part of these
activities of this Hughes
Professorship,
I've set up some seminars on
teaching.
And I've invited a guy from
Berkley named Robert Full who is
talking in
68-180 at 4:00 PM.
And I borrowed some things from
him this morning.
And we're just going to take a
quick tour because I want to
show you
this.
He works on,
well, he does a lot of things.
He works on
biomotion and how animals work.
But one of the things he works
on,
let's see if we can get this
guy to go here.
Oops.
How do I figure out
how to get it to play here?
Hang on a second.
I just discovered that
the PowerPoint is not really
terribly effective.
So this isn't working as nicely
as I would like.
OK.
Let's try this.
Just a minute.
Where are we?
Here we go.
OK.
Let's see if I can get
this to go.
So he studies a bunch of
things, but he did an undergrad
project library studying
geckos.
And here this is a transparent
surface.
And he's studying how the
geckos climb up and down the
thing.
And they were making
measurements.
And they found they couldn't
account
for why this was such an
efficient organism.
It used much less energy
than most things,
so they started looking into
how it adhered to the
surface.
It can go up a vertical wall,
as you can see here.
And so
they were able to look
underneath and they could see,
see how it sort
of peels off the surface?
And this was a robot that they
eventually
built that's not using the same
molecular bases but uses this
peeling thing.
And they can get a robot that
climbs up a wall.
But that's not what we're going
to talk about here.
We're going to
instead, I hope,
go back to here.
And you can see that all of the
geckos have these sort of
bizarre toes,
and so they started looking to
see what the underlying
principle of this was.
And they saw it has these
setae.
And they got looking in greater
detail and blew it up.
And then they found that there
were, as they started looking
there were
these little hairs.
And that's a 900-fold
magnification.
And once
they got looking in more detail
they found the ends were split
so that
they were, the very ends are
about 200 nanometers roughly at
the end of
this.
And so a gecko has about a
billion of these on its feet.
And
what it turns out it does --
And just to see,
here's a human
hair.
You see how it splits down?
Now, this is made of keratin,
the
molecule I just mentioned that
was used, alpha helices,
but it's very,
very fine.
And what it can do,
it can make van der Waals
interactions.
This is an animal that sticks
to the wall by van der Waals
interactions.
And the peeling away allows it
to break those bonds.
But, as you can see,
they're enormously important.
He's got here a micrograph.
They're measuring the force,
and the force
is just huge.
This is the end of the thing,
the frayed end sticking
to a surface.
And for those of you who didn't
think biology any
relevance to you,
Bob was telling me about this.
They followed up,
he's
an engineer as well and builds
interdisciplinary teams,
and they've
measured this stuff.
But this is turning into what
appears to look
like it's going to be a $30 to
$50 billion industry as all
sorts of things are -- They're
beginning to realize it can
hold car parts together,
it can go in space shuttles,
Post-it notes.
And here's a little Band-Aid
they made.
They own the patent on this
self-cleaning dry adhesive.
It doesn't have to be made out
of gecko
stuff.
It could be made out of all
sorts of things.
But, anyway,
here's an example of where not
only are van der Waals forces
very
important, but where somebody
who studied a very simply aspect
of
biology worrying about the
efficiency of how geckos ran and
pushed it all the way down to
the molecular level understood a
principal that's going to make
somebody a very large
amount of money.
OK.
The last, and if anybody wants
to come, he's an amazing
speaker.
Perhaps one of the most
exciting
speakers I've ever heard.
68-180, 4:00 PM if you want to
go.
He'll
have more of that sort of stuff
to show you then.
OK.
So the last force here,
it's not really a force,
but what we'll call
hydrophobic effects.
And what I mean by this is that
the principle
of this is that amino acids
that don't like to interact
with water, so --
So hydrophobic amino acids.
These are ones like lucine and
phenylalanine.
Well, I showed you the water
the other day and how it
was forming hydrogen bonds
between the molecules.
So if you're going
to stick another molecule in
there, you're going to break a
bunch of
bonds.
And if you're not charged or
polar you cannot make new bonds
with
the water.
And so what happens,
if you put these together,
just like if
you put oil together it will
all bundle up and it will
minimize its
interactions with water.
And that's what proteins do.
Here's
the structure of a protein all
folded up in 3-dimensional
space.
And you can see at the core of
the protein how there are these
many
hydrophobic amino acids that
are interacting.
And let me just,
I'm
going to close by showing you
one more little movie.
And the new
version of PowerPoint doesn't
do this well so I'm just going
to get
out of this for a second here.
This is a really cool movie I
saw.
I want to show you a DNA repair
protein sticking to a piece of
helix.
Can you hit the lights
somebody there?
So this is a lesion on a piece
of, see the
double helix here?
And what I especially liked
about
this is this is sort of a Star
Wars movie.
You're going to fly down the
major groove of a double helix.
And you can see where this
particular
protein folded up in
3-dimensional space is reaching
down into that
helix.
So this is sort of putting
together the two things that
I've
been telling you about.
This blue is a DNA repair
protein.
Oopsy daisy.
A DNA repair protein that's
able to
find a lesion in the DNA.
And here's the double helix
that's the
two chains held together by
hydrogen bonds.
And then, as you can see,
there's a groove on each side.
And the protein is searching
down into that groove --